[Music]
google's new career certificates program
is an
innovative approach to helping people
access technology careers
without a four-year post-secondary
degree at low cost users can access
google's platform
and acquire tech industry recognized
credentials in areas like it support
data analytics and android development
these certificates which can be
completed
in six to eight months qualify
credential holders for in-demand jobs
at competitive wages there are some
potential downsides to these career
certificates
today's hot new skill can quickly become
yesterday's news
workers have to be able to pivot a
successful career is built on a triad
strong basic skills technological
fluency and strong interpersonal skills
google certificates tick one of those
boxes but not all three
the exciting part is that google is
opening up a new alternative pathway to
a fast-growing
high-wage sector without the financial
and time burden of a degree
it's an important experiment a helpful
supplement to other education
and a trend worth watching closely what
kind of education and training do you
think is most helpful in today's economy
let us know in our poll also let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to like and subscribe for
more research and videos
from aei